[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، أرى نائب الرئيس أه
يمشي هنا أمام البيت الأبيض
، أول امرأة ملونة
مع
عائلتها ، كلمة عن الأمن هنا وهذا يبعث
على الارتياح
أه من الجميل أن أرى هذا لم يكن كذلك
على يقين من أنهم
سيغادرون أو الرئيس سيغادرون
الموكب لكنهم فعلوا ذلك ،
لقد تمكنا من رؤيتهم هنا ولكن
هذا يتحدث عن الخطر الأمني المتمثل في أن
م كانوا قادرين على فعل ذلك فقط في
خر 100
اردة أو 200 ياردة أو  إذن من رحلتهم
إلى البيت الأبيض ومبنى المكتب التنفيذي القديم ،
ما هي وظيفتك الأولى التي
تمشي إلى العمل ،
بالطبع ، يجب أن نلاحظ
أن مكتبها سيكون في
مبنى المكتب التنفيذي القديم هنا
بجوار البيت الأبيض  وهذا هو المكان
الذي ستمشي فيه إلى العمل اليوم
وأعتقد أن هذا جزء من الرسالة اليوم
لكل من هي
والرئيس ، وهما يباشران العمل على
أرض الواقع ، فلديهما
الكثير من العمل للقيام بهما
لأنهما سيكونان أوامر تنفيذية
اليوم.  إعادة ذاهب إلى  على وشك
الانتهاء والكشف عن خطتهم للتعامل مع
الوباء اليوم ، كل هذا يحدث
اليوم لحظة للاحتفال ولكن كما قالت
هناك إنها ستبدأ العمل